what's going on there citizens of the
reject Nation Greg's pointing at you
because you're a secret scroll you son
of a John how's it going I am terrific
sir how are you I'm doing well oh I'm
feeling good are you feeling good I am
feeling good and I'm feeling authentic
and original I am excited to talk about
secret Invasion guys we would love it if
you could do the deed of leaving a like
if you end up enjoying this video anyway
we got a bunch of Turners coming out
this week so subscribe and click that
notification Bell because trailers
Galore apparently all to get on that
Mario release let's do this
thank you
sure Nicholas
since you've been gone
I could breathe for the first time
you've gotten much worse
oh you think I came back
[Music]
why have you been gone
you're in no shape for this fight that
lies before us old friend
yeah
graphic awesome
this is personal
very few of us know about the wars
fought in the shadows that have raged on
this planet
do you feel responsible Clark
yes sir
where are the Avengers
a question
this war is one I have to fight alone
patchless Fury
man the music in this wanted man on the
planet
you don't know what they have planned
for you
the Great Neck Fury wow
God damn jeez
today
one last fight
oh
cool they do it oh excited to talk about
this yeah did you catch Quake I caught
Quake she was all over this trailer just
quaking everything left and right Agents
of Shield
quick testing she really just kind of
took the stage and didn't give anybody
else a chance to speak or be featured at
all like I don't know what the show's
even about no one does John no alrighty
guys well I love the trailer for this it
felt very cold and Atmospheric from the
first trailer to this one you just get
this like in the words of John Humphrey
this percolating dread thread it's the
whole atmosphere my phrase I love it
because this feels very serious
hearkening to the times of something
like Captain America Winter Soldier but
with more of a Sci-Fi angle to it that
has that Invasion of the Body Snatchers
quality as well and you get this like
sense of like a brimming War everywhere
around us we were talking on the live
stream the other day I was getting like
a cold war flare to it like we're on the
verge of something terrible going down
and we need to be on the lookout I love
the way it's shot because throughout the
whole cinematography there's constantly
this like greenish landscape and tint to
it
representing the Scrolls
that's hiding and playing filmmaking 101
right it's the observation that's why I
went to a film School online at Phoenix
and University yeah it's working 17 yeah
I was able to say like that John
that's right it's beautiful you know
especially with Nick Fury finally
getting his own Standalone his own story
to have a standalone property it's just
fun looking at it because you know when
this is clearly more picking up as a
sequel from the events of what happened
from Captain Marvel to now while
factoring in some other random
that's occurred since then you know from
what we were reading did you read the
Vanity Fair article I did okay good
let's just recite everything from there
this I speed read it good I slow Reddit
so between the two of us between the two
of us we should be able to find Common
Ground while talking about it Samuel
Jackson was kind of divulging a lot that
you know Emilia Clark's character is
going to be the daughter of Talos Gaia
her character was a little girl featured
in Captain Marvel now that you know the
time has passed the Scrolls have been
expecting to have a home by now because
that was one of Nick Fury's promise he
hasn't been able to uphold that promise
obviously so now you got kind of these
like factions of Scrolls where it feels
like some Scrolls they just want to like
rise at the surface and and find and
take take the planet one impression you
get and the other's like no there's got
to be a peaceful calm there's got to be
like a pacifistic way of going about
this we're gonna get something really
personal between Talos and Gaia because
Gaia is more on the rebellious end of it
and then you got Nick Fury who I get the
sense here you'll get more of like a
vulnerable quality to him versus the
more Stern strong in command I feel like
he's gonna rise back into that character
over the course of the series yeah
absolutely and I think that'll be a
really fun and interesting thing to see
because I believe he is
supposed to be in the Marvels to some
capacity so yeah it ruins that this is
not one last time then oh no well you
know I mean what's one last time when we
could be making those big bucks on a big
weekend and setting records uh but yeah
no no I like I love the idea of actually
zooming in on him and giving him a
journey that yeah will certainly be
physical and have a huge world-rending
stakes and all that stuff but that will
too uh probably yeah give him an
opportunity to have his like closest
people Maria Hill and Talos in this
struggle at least you know by his side
again who he's been estranged from for
so long while he's been off world doing
whatever he's been doing and uh and yeah
it would be nice to see some of Samuel L
Jackson's actual like acting chops I
mean we know he can be commanding as
Nick Fury but to you know get some of
the pathos would be a nice thing as well
and uh yeah like Emilia Clarke like I'm
rooting for this to be the time that she
really like fully brings me into a
character and I feel like this whole
show has a great amount of potential
because you know there have been both
times leading with just this tone and
this paranoia and the idea that anyone
could be you know your enemy hiding
right next to you and that's very
relevant to the here and now but that's
also easily you know lending to those
Cold Cold War themes and flavors that
they're bringing in who do you trust
John I don't trust anybody but Nick they
just gotta have a really funny scene
where everyone's just transforming left
and right yes and then they're all
transforming into you know Baskin
Robbins Scott Lang or something like
that I think what was so cool about
especially this one though is you there
is a sense of true Peril and Desperation
another one of John's words sure you had
it John enough you start to pick up on
some words that John says and then this
paranoia where now I feel so harsh new
words
yes I gotta stop saying sure all the
time to agree with things well it just
seems like there's a lot of emotional
weight you know one of my words because
there's a lot of emotional heft
throughout it and I love this sense of
paranoia that it's constantly spread
throughout here you know so I think it's
I think it's really cool because it
feels less like winter soldier but more
like a tinker Taylor Soldier spots that
is a great Touchstone actually because I
think the one of the creators said like
aside from you know TV of recent note
that you know Echoes these kinds of
themes uh uh John Kare the author's last
name is karei and he wrote Tinker Taylor
Soldier spies oh really a bunch of other
yeah novels oh how funny yeah spy
Espionage tales and whatnot so yeah
that's definitely in this okay mixture
here and this too to piggyback off the
Captain America thing like it it doesn't
uh it almost feels to like a more
substantial version of what Falcon in
the Winter Soldier was trying to bring
us with the whole flag Smashers thing in
a way I mean there's also like a this
almost reminds me too of like a dark
episode of Doctor Who in
trying to find a new home and some of
them are just tired of waiting and tired
of the bureaucracy and tired of the
unanswered promises and yeah now you
have this group fracturing and I I hope
that they take the opportunity to make
this you know like an actual piece of
allegorical fiction not just like a fun
adventure with these flavors wrapped you
know shrink wrapped on top you want to
see how it ties into the Multiverse of
saga that's what matters most to me John
well if they bring a quake maybe it will
I think it will you know finally get the
answer about where Agents of Shield
Sands and all this well what did you
guys think about this trailer for secret
Invasion did we do all right without koi
being here because that was the pressure
how bad did we fail how bad did we fail
koi could tell us that guy what the
Groot arm is we're just Talos and Maria
Hill and koi is out there off world just
floating around yeah I think Olivia
Coleman's her name yes I think she's a
red herring that's why they put her in
red
symbolism
well thank you
what did you think leave your thoughts
and predictions down below do you think
Talos will die hashtag Talos dead no hey
let's shout out some all right Adrian
Tims killer Kendrick noise
righteous Ryan Baines ribbed for your
pleasure Rob Frawley II Justice Jeffrey
Robinson righteous real nagas barf and
Barca Fano one jellicle jespreet
Boulevard riffing with Roberto Engelman
holy Heather gear ignites the Ian Simon
shout the Songhai Glover Jesus it's
Jacob Neptune
kooky Kayla the king awesome as always
Alan Ling lovely Logan Burton cook it in
the kitchen here
so it sounds
effervescent Eric Hans 39. kite flying
with
naughty Nick X dirty Dijon January
juicy Juan Longoria girthy Gail Ferguson
clapping Cliff Rodriguez
masturbatori Master T jump on John the
goat looking bastards Lorenzo Baxter
doing stuff differently same most
tenacious Marco Tunstall loquacious and
hellacious Lauren American Horse so
effin simply faded run kick Rogue Cree
writing essays with
sj-94 just match Johnston Martin running
backwards Rosie Beatty call me
Colin penis Jesus and Sicily Philip K
Smith Jr
[Laughter]
join Scientology Jen Smith milk and
ladies Melanie LeBlanc
you know I already did it it's the job
good theme today John I hope other
people picked up on it uh you know I
didn't dictate what the subject matter
would be just what the game parameters
could be so you know it's it's every
month that's that's the thing it's it's
a new experience you never know what's
coming off these domes except a couple
of you who we might have repeated over
time yeah righteous alrighty guys thanks
for being here and being part of our
page I hope to see you all next month
thanks
thank you